with shifting gears because we went from
like squaring and cubing a lot kind of
thing and now I'm taking this square
root or something so again let's go for
some easy values shall we uh what's well
I think there's only maybe there's only
one or two really good notice ordinates
I can pick here right
maybe just one and I want to give me a
suggestion yeah good when x equals to 1
the function y is going to be resumed ER
and I know what the squared of 0 it is
it's 0 and is that defined it is defined
right so therefore I'm gonna put a
filled circle there now I usually put
crosses through where I pastored but why
am I putting circle and filling it oh
good I know that this has endpoints
right it starts and it stops because the
square root can't exist when the number
at least in the real plane which is why
I'm graphing like right the square root
of this guy can't exists so therefore
between North sorry negative 1 and 1 not
in question
the graph doesn't exist ok so that's why
I put an in point there now I can also
see towards infinity over here right
what's this hacen took the horizontal
asymptote what 1 right so if I were to
get to y equals 1 I know what the square
root of 1 is as well it's 1 right but
now the question becomes just like I was
trying to argue in here
all right I'll take this square root so
I'm going to be below this component
graph or am I going to be above now take
a minute to think about this right
ticket it to me remember when we were
looking at squaring and cubing
right if you're less than 1 that makes
you closer to it makes you lower right
because like I rubbed it up cuz you know
9 tenths or 1/2 and you square it you
get lower but here I'm not swearing I'm
doing the opposite I am taking a square
root right so therefore rather be lower
rather be less I should be great a man
now let me just try to convince you this
numerically it's not hot
think about he's a he's a fraction
what's the square root of a quote is a
half bigger or smaller there to cut up
its bigger right so what I get out of
this if these two equal and they're
bigger than this guy then
the scripts are below the square root of
reporter is greater than a quarter right
in fact the square root of x this is
gonna be part on tables before in a
minute the screen room X is always
bigger than X provided provided what
provided that X is a fraction that's
between northern one right between
northern one so I can say you okay with
that does that make sense of course if I
am bigger right then it's completely
different you get it differently will
gets better second all that just argued
in here I'm going to be above okay so
I'm going to get this one baby
I know I can't possibly cross this
acetate sorry that what you're asking
that were you asked about the ground
yeah the acetate yeah I know I can't
cross the acetone because to get above y
equals one I would need to be taking the
square root it was some number bigger
than one right every number up here if
you square it will get you high up I
don't have any of those points of what
you mean like why doesn't it do that you
mean like like this a difficult cavity
okay how do I know it's going to be
concave down rather than poking up these
are all of the ornaments that I've taken
square root of right all these ordinates
here but every single one of those
ornaments it's this condition right
so therefore when I take the square root
I'm always going to be high up I have to
be higher right so therefore I'm always
up here now in order to be down here I
have to be concave I have to have the
wrong crew cavity right and they don't
have to be underneath here and pass
through but none of those values are
never going to do be outside of that
they're all between okay so that's why
this is okay all right now last a little
bit when I have a look up here like
what's happening with these numbers are
all above think about the ordinates
they're all about one so again I'm going
to try to make this argument over here
okay I'm going to say well let's think
of a number above one I've got the
square number because I want how much
favorite survive is a square root of 4
the square root of 4 is 2 2 is less than
4 right now these two guys are equal and
they're both less than 4 then I conclude
that the square root of 4 is less than 4
in other words the square of X is always
less than X provided rather than being
in this kind of value
right if X is bigger right I'm always
gonna beat the load that makes sense the
square root of a number let's grab a big
nut we less than that number square root
25 is 5 squared 100 is 10 that's very
Remington 44 it's 12 right so square
roots up beneath the numbers they're
squaring if we're up there okay so
therefore since they're all beneath
it's going to do something like this
right see the argument you need to make
to the girl that's how to do a square
root graph it's not that complicated
we'll do one more example and then when
you're title up in a summary okay be
graphed while you um you can get started
while I tidy up my board see how what I
try to do is I've put my components in
green I frequently do that because green
like you guys completely clearly see
it's like oh that's not the main one
like black or blue is gonna be like it's
gonna stand out more to me when I look
at your graph is this other stuff on
there I should be able to tell in the
fraction of a second which one's the
real rap now if that's difficult because
you know you're just doing it with old
black pencil okay um then you're gonna
need to rub off your components so I can
see your actual graph by the end